amanda bynes says she's sober and ready
to return to acting during her first
sit-down interview in years I'm doing
great thank you
really great the once troubled actress
sat down for an interview with Holly
scoops Diana Madison and revealed that
she's three years sober I hike I go
spinning take spinning classes and I
feed the homeless
Amanda experienced multiple brushes with
the law including two hit-and-run
charges and two DUI arrests as well as a
flurry of disturbing tweets when you
told rape to murder your vagina I
actually wasn't being insincere I was
like saying murder my vagina uh-huh
we're serious I was serious but I was
also on drugs so that was my way of
saying like let's do it anyway but I was
like on drugs and trying to be hilarious
after all of that and a hospital stay
under a psychiatric hold
in 2014 the former child star retreated
from the spotlight she kind of
resurfaced in 2016
revealing online that she was taking
classes at the Fashion Institute of
Design and Merchandising I've learned
how to sew I meet patterns and I want to
start a clothing line in the future the
31 year old who starred in all that
she's the man and what I like about you
also says she's ready to return to the
small screen
I do miss acting and actually have
something surprising to tell you I'm
going to start acting again yes I want
to do TV maybe a few guest spots on some
shows but I'm a fan of and maybe another
TV show where I'm the star of it
you